all right victoria turning to sports
coverage tonight the raiders wrap up
their preseason slate tomorrow night in
the bay as they take on the san
francisco 49ers john gruden may not play
a lot of the starters again and as john
treach is here to explain sunday's game
is one last audition for many guys to
make the team john imagine getting close
to 80 players on the roster and then
having to tell 27 of them you're not
wanted it's one of the hardest coldest
feelings of being a head coach but with
a handsome salary comes the ugly
decisions in three days john gruden and
general manager mike mayak will call 27
guys who fought for the silver and black
to come to the office and bring your
playbook training camp is reaching a
culmination and so is the raider
experience for many players both young
and old and a game full of emotion
sacrifice long hours and long locker
room talks this conversation won't be
fun every team is saying that right now
you know you can only keep 53. problem i
have is i get attached to these guys you
know i just love being around the
players you know trey trey regis and bj
emmons and we you know garrett rose
shake these guys we've had a lot of fun
with dj turner and some of these guys
and uh you know when the general manager
says you can't keep them all you can
only keep six or you can only keep five
or you can only keep four
uh
there'll be some there'll be some
arguments for sure and i'm really proud
of our players and coaches for putting
us in this situation
perhaps you can relate as someone who
wants to be liked and keep people happy
i do not envy the next few days for john
gruden and the staff tomorrow's audition
kicks off at 1 pm and will be shown on
channel 8.